the man who co-produced my first movie
and who remains a great light in my life
tonight receives the Jean Hersholt Award
it is an honor
earned only by one whose humanitarian
efforts dignify the film community and
bring honor to our society and so it's
not given every year in the past the
Hersholt has been presented to a dozen
actors half a dozen producers seven
executives one writer director and yes
one agent this year a musician has
qualified for the honor and I have the
wonderful privilege of ratifying the
Academy Board of Governors unanimous
choice he is the maestro his colleagues
call Q I call friend and the world calls
mr. Jones mr. Quincy Jones
so now you know why I am so proud to
give this Jean Hersholt Humanitarian
Award to my friend I just love him mr.
Quincy Jones
thank you it's nice to feel important I
think maybe a bit more important to film
that'd be nice so this moment this
evening the spot where I stand tonight
was not my destination when I was young
and full of vinegar
I did not engineer this journey to tell
you the truth I don't think I could even
see this far and now that I'm older and
full of wonder I can see that maybe
other forces were at the wheel you may
have seen my mother Sarah in my music
and witnessed the laughter and tears of
my children my family they were the
pillows beneath this life of mine
there's just a humanity reflected in
this moment you may be familiar with
countless of shoulders that I stood upon
to just see where I might go they were
the pillows that were beneath my life
theirs is the humanity reflected in this
moment I also hope you can see
reflections to the gift of friendship so
generously given to me by Benny Carter
Sidney Poitier Boston Happy Birthday moe
Clarence Avant and Steve Ross my gurus
of givingness and a multitude of others
who to have been pillars beneath this
life of mine I accept this great honor
in their names on this the proudest day
of my life thank you governess at the
academy for including me in such
prestigious company and you Americans
out there please join the rising support
for the National Endowment for the Arts
each act of creation can be another
powerful pillar beneath this life of
this wonderful and trouble nation of
ours who knows the next artistry support
may one day stand before you as I do now
humble proud cool and so thankful thank
you all
Paul Newman Jamie Lee Curtis and Tim
Allen will join us nuts on their cat